gilles verdez pour vous vous vous restez
sur vos positions
vous pensez vraiment que evian en
s'excusant derrière a fait une erreur et
en mettant surtout ce tweet vous pensez
vraiment que c'est une provocation ou es
ce que vous avez réfléchi vous ai dit
non c'est peut-être d'une connerie hier
dit la vérité ou alors je maintiens
totalement mes propos je vous avoue que
la journée était difficile parce qu'il
ya quand même un non pas un déferlement
mais ma prise de position je le sais est
minoritaire et là il ya eu énormément de
messages négatifs et beaucoup occasion
quel type de message qu'est ce alors il
ya eu beaucoup de messages et c'est bien
que monsieur messia soit là parce qu'il
ya eu énormément de messages lancés par
les séides extrême droite de monsieur
messia après un tweet qu'il a bien su
hier soir vaut presque jamais ça on va
voir on peut enfin de gens étaient plus
de pouvoir alors qu'alicia jules verne s
perd les pédales pour lui avait en
france sur les coupables d' islamophobie
et data contre le ramadan pour un tweet
sur la consommation d'eau il y à un
traitement pour l'islamo gauchisme
démentiel point d'interrogation à la
longue ça c'est violent et je dois vous
dire que c'est la vitalité monsieur
messias et qui lançait ses idées sa
défaire leurs démarches et je reconnais
aussi monsieur je reconnais aussi et je
le dis avec totale honnêteté cyril que
beaucoup de musulmans
beaucoup de musulmans mondy m'ont dit je
ne suis pas sûr que ta position malgré
la bonne volonté que tu avais été très à
droite parce que ça peut nous créer des
problèmes alors que nous on veut faire
le ramadan tranquillement ça mais
j'entends parfaitement est ce qu'il ya
et je le redis il ya très peu de
musulmans qui se tient à peine pas le
meilleur qui se sont plaints de cette de
se demander en fait ils ont rien demandé
les paumes et ça leur est tombée dessus
donc qui a fait ça qui est
instrumentalisé ça en valait de vol et
je vous le dis oui mais des trolls
willis et curieux parce que je vous le
dis c'est quand même mais une polémique
qui est arrivé et je le vois sur les
réseaux sociaux et on voit sur les
commentaires qui a eu sur les différents
réseaux on voit qu'ils sont ne sont pas
du tout des personnes qui font le
ramadan ou qui se sont insurgés contre
cette pub mais contre evian et qui ont
dénoncé cette provocation contre le
ramadan donc est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a voulu faire
qui a voulu faire du mal à je sais pas
peut-être à la communauté musulmane a
peut-être un qui profitent exactement
c'est assez curieux cette affaire le
problème c'est surtout la réaction des
visions à la limite parce que d'abord
les musulmans n'ont rien demandé
moi j'ai pas un ami musulman qui a
trouvé le tweet de déviants choquant
mais ceci n'est qu'une poignée ou des
dizaines ou des centaines ou des
milliers de petites extrémistes sur
twitter qu'ils font sur le compte pour
dire provocation en provocation à la
limite evian aurait dû rester droit dans
ses bottes et ne rien lâcher mais c'est
le tweet d' excuse qui est absolument
hallucinant c'est ça qui provoque la
polémique quant à gilles verdez si vous
voulez paix tandis que c'est une
provocation rivière évidemment mais
s'ils voulaient gilles verdez est un
vautour de l'islamo gauchisme d'accord
dès qu'il voit un truc qu'il peut
rivaliser avec la racaille aux sphères
où l'islam au ce faire ils font dessus
pour s'envoler avec ans va franchement
accusé le groupe danone qui est l'un des
groupes qui a le plus fait en matière de
diversité en matière d'inclusion en
matière d'environnement d'islamophobie
c'est vraiment se [ __ ] de leur appel
aux donateurs qui vient en fait partie
du groupe danone voilà parce qu'il ya
des gens qui voient là à telle enseigne
d'ailleurs que le pdg est en train de
débarquer parce qu'il ne faisait plus
que ça alors que les actionnaires
attendent surtout des sous et non pas
des ballons en forme et en forme de
coeur